what you can service thing about Muslims
I was I'm sick um
Muslims are considered them
I think the problem got a lot what was
question what to conserve to think about
Muslims we believe that Muslim
terrorists good 20% of Muslims are as
bad as the the 12% of Germans who are
Nazis nothing wrong with want some
radical Islam that's the problem
troublemakers most of them perfectly
good people excuse me let me qualify
that conservatives I'm talking about
myself they need to get the religion in
order good series I don't think have any
disdain towards Muslims or any religious
paper groove it until they are willing
to share our belief systems if we see
start seeing churches popping up in some
you know Arab lands then I'll be a
little bit more willing to accept
peaceful religion and some frayed edges
I think most conservatives recognize
that there are extremes and a lot of
religions Muslims in itself that there's
I have most impressed they were very
peaceful people that there is a branch
that are radical radical Islam is not
something that's good mixed reactions I
think people tend to conservatives tend
to associate that with radical Islam
Muslims are okay they're they're cool I
think that we need everyone to decide
which Muslims are radical we need to go
after them jihadis they need to be
defeated because they're not good for
Muslims either the generalization is in
here in the question
Muslims are cool I mean most religions
are and as long as you're not being
violent towards others and keeping
yourself
you